east of Westeros lies the smoking sea
where no ship dare sail there are those
who swear it to be demon haunted and
who's to say they're wrong for it was
there thousands of years ago that a
cataclysmic event occurred destroying
one of the great civilizations in
history the precise details of their
origins are lost to us but it is said
the Valyrians were once a modest
community of Shepherds tending their
flocks on a small Peninsula of the Great
Eastern continent one fateful day in a
volcanic area known as the 14 fires they
made a shattering discovery dragons they
were monstrous scaled creatures with
massive wings sharp claws and fiery
breath they were also said to have a
deep-rooted connection to magic in time
the Valyrians were able to tame the
beasts harnessing their immense power
they established a city of wonder unlike
any before or since they became skilled
at sorcery and metallurgy creating
uncommon weapons of spell forged steel
wielding these weapons astride their
dragons the Valyrians conquered the
surrounding lands and slowly expanded
West at the time the ghiscari Empire
dominated much of the great eastern
continent and tried to stop Valeria's
expansion the ghiscari legions attacked
the Valerians five times but could never
defeat them finally the Valyrians
marched on their capital olgas and
obliterated it turning its streets and
buildings to ash with dragon flame and
wiping the ghiscari people and their
culture off the face of the earth the
freehold of Valyria as it came to be
known became the most advanced
civilization in the known world with its
own language gods and culture the
Valerians reach extended far and wide
covering most of the continent great
cities were built and roadways paved all
of which led back to the
area the freehold would prosper for
nearly 5,000 years but it was not to
last
an event that became known only as the
doom laid waste to the Valyrians their
capital city and its surrounding lands
the peninsula itself was shattered
becoming what is now the smoking scene
every Dragon was thought to be lost as
were the Valyrian spells knowledge and
recorded history thus the mighty Empire
collapsed what caused this Cataclysm no
one knows for certain some say it was a
volcanic eruption others say the
Valyrian zoned sorcery got the better of
them in any event the dooms devastation
of the Valyrian people was total with
the exception of a small rocky island in
the Narrow Sea Dragonstone for it was
there that the Targaryen the last of all
Valeria dwelled they would lie in wait
for another hundred years before
unleashing the fury of the dragon on
another continent Westeros